rendez vous manqués à la ciotat le
chantier naval repris par bernard tapie
n'a pas rouvert ses portes comme prévu
le 1er septembre la cgt portent plainte
mais c'est un concurrent américain qui
bloquerait pour l'instant le redémarrage
le malaise de la gendarmerie l'ancien
ministre la défense charles hernu
trentaine de propositions pour la
première fois il n'est pas d'accord avec
le ministre actuel monsieur chevènement
sur l'analyse du malaise documents à
l'appui la rédaction d'antenne 2
apportera la preuve que la situation en
azerbaïdjan entre la minorité arménienne
et la population musulmane n'a fait que
s'envenimer ces derniers mois les
convois sont attaqué des hommes torturer
les arméniens forment des groupes armés
d'autodéfense madame monsieur bonsoir un
véritable était de chiens pour la corse
après la sécheresse et les incendies de
juillet et d'août les inondations de
septembre des pluies diluviennes se sont
abattues jusqu'à ce matin de bonne heure
sur la région de la haute corse
des torrents de boue ont coupé les
routes envahies des campings et des
villages environ 600 personnes ont dû
être évacuées ce samedi le beau temps
était revenu accélérant la décrue mais
les prévisions météo ne sont pas
fameuses nathalie dollé
après une nuit de cauchemar voici la
plaine orientale de haute corse
des milliers d'hectares de terres
inondées des cultures de kiwis et des
vignes complètement détruite
600 personnes en majorité des touristes
ont dû être évacuées et relogées dans
des écoles ou dans des cinémas de la
région d'aléria on se demande
aujourd'hui pourquoi des villages de
vacances ou des campings ont obtenu
l'autorisation de s'installer sur des
zones inondables en 24 heures à peine
il a plu autant qu'en un mois normal
après la sécheresse de cet été les
nombreux incendies
les autorités craignent maintenant des
éboulements et des glissements de
terrain
le préfet pourrait demander l'état de
catastrophe naturelle
les maires de nous communiquer tous les
renseignements nécessaires à présenter
cette demande et
si effectivement les dossiers le
justifie je ferai cette demande auprès
des ministères concernés puisque vous
savez que cet état de catastrophe
naturelle est reconnu par une décision
interministérielle
aujourd'hui il n'a plus que légèrement
sur la haute corse
et si 2000 foyers restent encore privés
d'électricité
la circulation a pu être rétablie mais
les prévisions de pluie et de grêle pour
demain maintiennent toujours les
pompiers en alerte inondations en corse
sécheresse et incendie dans une garrigue
dans les bouches du rhône à fare les
oliviers
plusieurs avions canadair se sont rendus
sur place le feu a pris aux environs de
17 heures cet après midi on peut penser
à des incendies criminels dans la mesure
où on a enregistré 13 départs de feu
dans des endroits différents
actuellement dans cette région
le mistral souffle à près de 50 km h les
chantiers navals de la ciotat en cale
sèche en effet hier 1er septembre aux
termes d'un accord signé c'était au mois
de juillet dernier entre les pouvoirs
publics
le repreneur bernard tapie les syndicats
devaient donc redémarré hier et pourtant
il irait bien il ne s'est rien passé
la cgt a donc décidé de porter plainte
mais la sphère est plus complexe qu'il
n'y paraît si bernard tapie était absent
c'est qu'un groupe américain veut
également s'installer sur place est pour
l'instant un gars le gouvernement
français n'est pas d'accord ce qui a
pour effet donc de bloquer la
réouverture en attendant la décision de
justice en quête de patrice blais et à
la noblesse qui le 8 juillet dernier les
salariés des chantiers de la ciotat
explose de joie
le groupe bernard tapie est autorisée à
racheter une partie du chantier pour y
construire des navires de haute
plaisance
l'activité débutera le 1er septembre or
hier rien ne se passe la cgt affirme ne
pas comprendre et nous on se présenter
le 1er septembre travail
pas de repreneur pas de patron nous
avons assigné le groupe tapie et le
gouvernement qui n'ont pas tenu les
engagements de l'accord de huiyan fortis
interrogé le groupe tapie nous a répondu
nous n'avions accès ni aux chantiers ni
au matériel explication entre temps le
groupe américano suédois l'ex marc lui
aussi candidat au rachat a déposé
plainte estimant que les terrains
attribués au groupe tapie devait lui
revenir en vertu de la règle du plus
offrant décision de justice mardi
prochain en attendant les donc
juridiquement impossible d'entamer la
moindre activité sur les lieux la cgt
aurait dû être au courant estimé
pouvoirs publics une lettre signée tapis
expliquant tout cela lui avait été
envoyée puis afficher sur le chantier
dans cette lettre
bernard tapie s'engage si la décision de
justice défavorable à embaucher 300
personnes avec effet rétroactif au 1er
septembre la cgt préfère la proposition
lexmark qui envisage l'embauché de deux
mille personnes pour fabriquer des
pétroliers les deux projets ne
pourrait-il pas cohabiter dans l'absolu
oui mais le gouvernement estime que la
proposition lexmark est très flou et
qu'elle pourrait déboucher à terme sur
un nouveau constat de faillite
le malaise de la gendarmerie un homme
politique qui connaît bien le problème
donne pour la première fois aujourd'hui
son point de vue qu'il s'agit de charles
hernu ancien ministre socialiste de la
défense lui-même
faut-il le préciser fils de gendarme
charles hernu ne partage pas l'analyse
de l'actuel ministre jean pierre
chevènement sur les raisons de ce
malaise
il le dit clairement à bernard cadinot
pour lui il n'y a pas de complot et le
problème ne date pas d'hier monsieur
hernu participé aujourd'hui aux
cérémonies marquant dans sa ville de
villeurbanne le 45e anniversaire de la
liberté monsieur hernu il faut un plan
général de 6 ans au moins pour
revaloriser la gendarmerie et l'armée
y at il un complot de la droite ou bien
de la presse
écoutez le ministre de la défense a fait
allusion quelque chose comme ça et s'il
l'a dit c'est que sans doute il en a des
preuves mois en ce qui me concerne j'ai
reçu beaucoup de lettres de gendarmes
elle était signée je n'ai pas eu le
sentiment que des formations politiques
ou des médias aux deux responsables
politiques cherchait à récupérer ce
mouvement que l'on sentait venir les
gendarmes par le plus de conditions du
travail que d'argent
est ce qu'on ne fait pas fausse route en
recrutant à nouveau ne faut pas faire de
démagogie
à mon avis il y as besoin de 5000 postes
de gendarmes dire qu'on créera 5000 aux
gendarmes en six mois un an deux ans
trois ans ce n'est pas possible ils
jettent herman on ne sommes pas en état
de le faire
le fond du problème qui est un peu
surpris qu'on le boiteux ce n'est pas la
revendication salariale dont il parle ce
n'est pas d'avoir des matériels plus
performants
ce n'est pas d'être mieux équipée c'est
même pas d'avoir un meilleur logement il
faut le faire pour suivre l'évolution
d'une société
mais le non dit de tout cela c'est une
revendication d'être considérés comme
des hommes dans une située dans une
société qui a évolué c'est a besoin de
dignité d'être reconnue je crois que
c'est ça qu'il ya derrière et ça ne date
pas du gouvernement
car bien sûr ça date depuis des années
monsieur chevènement at il bien senti
venir le mouvement et le gouvernement
comment gère-t-il cette crise
comment voyez vous je me permettre de
juger le gouvernement
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure que monsieur
chirac au moment de la passation des
pouvoirs aurait dit premier ministre
michel rocard
faites attention à ce qui se passe dans
jamboree il faut pas croire que les
médias ont créé le malaise conclusion de
monsieur hernu la gendarmerie et l'armée
ne doivent pas souffrir des rivalités
entre les ministres de la défense et de
l'intérieur
oui alors qu'il ne connaissait pas
encore et pour cause la déclaration de
monsieur charles hernu jean pierre
chevènement qui se trouvait aujourd'hui
dans les hautes-alpes pour participer
aux universités d'été du ps a eu cette
phrase prémonitoire en quelque sorte
j'aimerais at il dit que le ps soutienne
ceux qui sont au front il faisait donc
allusion à lui-même est le nouveau
directeur gendarmerie annonce les
premières mesures qui vont immédiatement
prendre effet exemple recrutement de 500
gendarmes professionnels dès le mois
d'octobre 89 et rénovation des
casernements mais pas question de
démilitariser la gendarmerie le silence
est loin loin vraiment loin de retomber
sur les millions de morts dahouche fitz
la polémique entre juifs et catholiques
peut même peut tourner à la crise ce
soir après les déclarations faites
aujourd'hui par le primat de pologne le
cardinal glemp il veut renégocier les
accords qui avait abouti à la décision
de départ des carmélites du sit down
feat
monseigneur glaive qualifie autre part
de scandaleuse la requête demandant le
départ de ces religieux cette
déclaration intervient au terme d'une
semaine pendant laquelle le pape avait
essayé dans la coulisse de résoudre le
problème directement avec l'archevêque
de cracovie et non pas avec le chef de
l'église polonaise
ceci explique peut être cela enquête amk
insurgés yanncik ses cendres
appartiennent au vide et au silence du
monde déclaration en forme d'hommage de
monseigneur gaillot l'évêque d'evreux
hier à auschwitz pour tenter une
médiation apaisement que ne souhaite
apparemment pas monseigneur glem le
primat de pologne entend maintenant
renégocier l'accord de genève
en février 87 celui ci stipulait que les
carmélites quittent le camp dans les
deux ans en mars dernier l'épiscopat
polonais ratifie l'accord pourtant
aujourd'hui et 18 cars mellick sont
toujours là et monseigneur glemp
renchérit c'est un scandale de demander
le départ des soeurs qui prient pour les
chrétiens martyrisés et organisations
juives s'indigne d'une telle déclaration
la pologne a demandé que l'ensemble des
camps d'auschwitz birkenau soit classé
dans le patrimoine mondial est la base
même des accords sur le patrimoine
mondial c'est qu'on ne doit pas changer
la nature et la signification des lieux
qui en font partie
personne ne viendra renégocier avec
quelqu'un qui renie sa propre
approbation d accord mon sentiment c'est
que il y a eu des millions de morts
suisse et qu'il serait temps que
l'église catholique veuille bien
rétablir le silence dans cet endroit où
sont morts en hommes tant de femmes et
tant d'enfants ont il se trouve que tous
étaient juifs
les organisations juives attendent
aujourd'hui un geste du pape jean paul
ii a rencontré cette semaine
l'archevêque de cracovie signataires de
l'accord et dont dépend le carmel le
vatican aurait dit on pas l'intention de
revenir sur l'accord et pourrait exiger
sous peu le départ des carmélites le
gouvernement américain principal
intéressé dans la lutte contre les
trafiquants de drogue colombiens a
décidé dès aujourd'hui samedi d'expédier
du matériel militaire à bogota
principalement des avions et des
hélicoptères qui seront suivis de
conseiller mais pour l'instant pas
question de gi's sur le territoire
colombien en attendant et bien la
colombie connaît toujours un climat de
violence qui s'est manifesté il ya
quelques heures par l'explosion d'un
camion piégé dans la capitale bogota
pascal deschamps scène presque
quotidiennes désormais dans les rues de
bogota la capitale un immeuble ravagé
par un attentat bilan un mort et 38
blessés
la cible le quotidien libéral el
espectador qui soutient ouvertement le
gouvernement dans sa lutte contre les
trafiquants déjà il ya deux ans son
directeur avaient été assassinés
scènes quotidiennes à medellin la
deuxième ville du pays fief du trop
célèbre cartel chaque nuit les centaines
de personnes sont arrêtées pour non
respect du couvre-feu
en tout quatre mille hommes des forces
de sécurité patrouillent dans les rues
de la ville
mais selon le maire lui même il en
faudrait encore beaucoup plus c'est dans
ce contexte qu'est intervenu hier soir à
washington l'annoncé par le porte parole
du pentagone des premières livraisons de
matériel militaire
deux gros porteur c 130 ont décollé il
ya quelques heures d'une base du
kentucky avec à bord des petits
hélicoptères de combat et un lot de
gilets pare balles destinées au juge
menacée
à voir également des conseillers
militaires chargés uniquement de former
les colombiens au maniement de ce
matériel aucun soldat américain ne doit
participer au combat comme l'a promis le
président bush et pourtant
l'intervention américaine semble ne pas
faire l'unanimité au sein du
gouvernement folon bien si vous voulez
vraiment nous aider a dit en substance
le ministre de la défense hier soir
commencez par ne plus consommer de
cocaïne les terroristes irlandais de
l'ira renault avec les attentats sur le
territoire de l'allemagne de l'ouest
contre des soldats britanniques qui sont
stationnés hamster hier soir deux
militaires anglais en civil ont été
grièvement blessés par les occupants
d'une voiture qui s'étaient arrêtés pour
leur demander leur chemin à quelques
mètres à peine de l'entrée de la caserne
l'ira a officiellement revendiqué
l'attentât heureusement bien que très
grièvement touché la vie des deux hommes
n'est pas en danger déclare qu'on se
soit
au liban on a très nettement
l'impression après les duels
d'artillerie de la nuit dernière et de
ce matin que la diplomatie a une
nouvelle fois laissé la place aux tirs
de canon la syrie et ses alliés tentent
même d'ouvrir de nouveaux fronts contre
les chrétiens
patricia kaas la pression militaire sur
le réduit chrétiens remonte trois jours
de bombardements presque ininterrompue
jusqu'à ce matin sur le littoral bien
sûr mais aussi sur la ligne de
démarcation à souk el gharbi et devant
bickfaya avec comme chaque fois la
réplique du camp chrétien sur les
régions musulmanes en l'absence de toute
perspective diplomatique les efforts de
paris et de moscou semble dans l'impasse
c'est de nouveau la guerre d'usure entre
les deux camps
avec la la fable va et vient de ceux qui
fuient et de ceux qui reviennent à la
moindre accalmie
car la vie n'a toujours pas perdu ses
droits au liban quelques mois de
quelques semaines plus exactement de
silence par manque d'information sur le
différend entre la minorité arménienne
d'azerbaïdjan et la population musulmane
locale n'ont pas empêché le conflit de
s'envenimer très sérieusement
aujourd'hui à bakou la capitale de
l'azerbaïdjan musulmane plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'azéris se sont
rassemblés pour réclamer le maintien de
la souveraineté de l'azerbaïdjan sur la
région du karabagh à majorité arménienne
mais sur le terrain à la lisière des
régions contestées le face-à-face
tournent maintenant à la haine déclarée
entre les deux populations et aux
conflits armés
le document exceptionnel que nous vous
présentons ce soir leproux il a été
tournée clandestinement les semaine
dernière dans des villages où les
arméniens se sont isolés lâché par tous
y compris par le pouvoir central de
moscou commentaires de thierry calme
dans ce village du sud de l'azerbaïdjan
les paysans arménien travaillent la peur
au ventre
lavez les peaux de mouton dans la
montagne une tâche quotidienne qui peut
se transformer parfois en un danger
mortel
fin juillet dans le hameau d'à côté
l'eau n'arrive plus deux hommes montrent
pas la source
on les découvre au plus tard massacrés
par des azéri d'origine turque
les reds azéri se multiplient un millier
de victimes à soumgaït temps février 88
et autant de morts depuis jusqu'à
aujourd'hui son nom or ces plaines
leeuwen 52 ans gorge tranchée
dieuze arracher images tournées
clandestinement l'hôpital de stéphane
acquette la capitale du haut karabagh le
27 juillet dernier à 9 heures du matin
deux nouvelles victimes de ranaz et
riviane d'arrivée écoutez les rescapés
ont raconté des cruautés d'un autre âge
sur nos plaies ils ont versé une sorte
donné l'assaut sur vos plaies oui
sari ils ont versé de la mélasse et puis
du sel sur nos belles su qu ils
voulaient nous arrosé d'essence et nous
voler et les miliciens il était avec
vous ils n'ont rien essayé de faire il
vous en laissez tout seul il était bien
debout près nous est l'un des deux a dit
allez ça suffit les gars vous voyez bien
qu'ils sont morts
les arméniens en terre en dés leur une
victime de plus saine de plus en plus
fréquentes en azerbaïdjan
autre danger se déplacer les convois
escortés se multiplient attaquez osent
aussi comme le 31 juillet sur cette
route entre goris et le haut karabagh 15
miliciens soviétiques n'ont pu résister
à la tête de 300 azéri une plaque
d'immatriculation arménienne signifie
cible privilégiée pérestroïka oblige les
délégués des autres républiques
soviétiques rendent visite au haut
karabagh pour calmer les esprits mais
les arméniens n'y croit plus
la pérestroïka la pérestroïka y en avait
une en 1920 et ça nous a subi la colère
succède à la résignation à guetter
chaîne vie l'azerbaïdjan la révolte
couve et familles arméniennes vis ici
depuis le 7ème siècle les turcs peut y
arrive cinq siècles plus tard et staline
en 1920 annexes l'azerbaïdjan est en
fait une république azéri avec
gouvernement azéri et une culture azéri
ici on n'oublie pas qu'avant et il
existera toujours ce qu'ils veulent que
le village soit rattachée au karabagh
que le haut karabagh soit rattachée la
république d'arménie soviétique qui ne
veulent plus être pourchassés après les
attaques de février les villages forme
des comités d'autodéfense clandestins
bien sûr à moscou le pouvoir central
s'en inquiète et on voit en mars des
émissaires à guetter chaîne il est venu
une délégation d'arméniens soviétique je
veux citer les noms si vous voulez
mourra bien en me voyant si haillan ils
nous ont plus ou moins réconforter il
n'y aura plus de représailles
nous sommes organisés sans eux et
quelques semaines après les lectures qui
arrivent et les turcs les azéri les
voisins les deux communautés vivent dans
les mêmes conditions mais en même me r
et du ter apparemment irréconciliables
nos grands pères et nos pères nous ont
appris que les arméniens et bien ce sont
nos ennemis ce sont des chrétiens et
nous nous sommes musulmans ils disent
que ce sont leurs terres ici ils veulent
leur attachement aux caravanes ou non le
village triplement isolé arménien est
entouré de turcs azéri chrétiens contre
musulmans
trois mille ans d'histoire séparé à
l'école les enfants apprennent les
exploits des héros arméniens mais les
écoliers subissent des attaques en
chemin certains instituteurs leur
enseigne aussi l'auto défense
dans les représailles nos enfants
étaient terrorisés alors nos enfants dès
l'âge de 10 ans après la classe nous
leur apprenons à se défendre
non pas ici dans d'autres endroits dans
la montagne ces cavaliers les premiers
groupes armés constitués en union
soviétique depuis des dizaines d'années
armement ce mr uniforme folklorique
comment les classes et rebelle
guérilleros résistant e n'évoque que
l'autodéfense contre les azéris
professeur employés paysans ils
acceptent d'être filmé à découvert car
ils n'ont plus rien à perdre
nous sommes ici depuis treize siècles
nous comptons bien y rester encore très
nos frères nos soeurs de la diaspora
doivent savoir que des médicaments des
vivres et des vêtements
c'est très bien mais que cela ne suffit
pas il est vital qu'ils nous envoient
des armes et des armes telles que nous
puissions les utiliser pour nous
défendre efficacement des armes pour
tuer encore la longue indifférence de
l'état soviétique envers les arméniens
d'azerbaïdjan peut conduire à la lutte
armée
un problème brûlant pour monsieur
gorbatchev et sa nouvelle politique
retour à des préoccupations de politique
intérieure française avec d'abord un
sondage très favorable au premier
ministre et au président de la
république réalisé par l'ifop pour le
journal du dimanche entre le 28 et le 31
août monsieur mitterrand compte 50 % de
satisfaits contre 43 en juillet monsieur
k 52% d'avis positifs contre 44 en
juillet touche universités d'été des
partis politiques dans les hautes-alpes
les socialistes ont été à moitié
convaincu par le premier ministre
monsieur rocard et son idée de pacte de
croissance pour les français qui ne
signifie pas simplement augmentation des
salaires mais création d'emplois et de
déformations compatible avec la vence de
l'économie française
reportage de jean michel mercurol et
philippe bas
chahuté par les militants après à ces
vérités dans la terre les gendarmes jean
pierre chevènement a su ce matin
retourner la salle en sa faveur et
conquérir son public
en revanche le pacte de croissance
révélée hier par michel rocard n'a pas
vraiment soulevé l'enthousiasmé des
socialistes de risoul parce que c'est le
plan du gouvernement ils les
soutiendrons mais visiblement il en
demandait plus en matière de partage et
de revalorisation des salaires
ils demandaient plus parce qu'ils ont
peur de se couper de leur base
électorale en ne répondant pas à ces à
la demande sociale une inquiétude
partagée au gouvernement par michel
delebarre
si l'action gouvernementale où l'action
des socialistes collectivement est vécu
comme comportant des éléments de déficit
social
alors ce n'est pas l'action qui est
attendu par le peuple de gauche ce n'est
pas l'action qui est attendu par les
hommes et des femmes de progrès étant ce
débat que nous allons avoir sur la
notion de pacte de croissance nous
devons apporter la preuve à ce temps
nous recherchons le dialogue avec
acharnement et volonté considérable que
notre ambition est une ambition de
progrès social même si les modalités de
mise en oeuvre sont l'objet de débats
entre nous et de progressivité dont il
faut accepter qu'elles soient
éventuellement contester c'est un sacré
chantier qui s'ouvre devant nous bref à
risoul les socialistes ont repris de la
hauteur vis-à-vis du pacte de croissance
ils attendent d'en voir les effets sur
la rentrée sociale avant d'en juger
le bien fondé l'université d'été des
centristes du cds à ramatuelle dans le
midi donc les centristes objet de toutes
les convoitises mais qui n'ont pu encore
véritablement concrétiser aucun de leurs
objectifs
eh bien ils ont poussé leur président
pierre méhaignerie ambitionner un poste
de premier ministre d'une nouvelle forme
de cohabitation et pourquoi pas mais
invoquer un destin présidentiel
olivier werner s'était fait quelle
mouche a donc piqué pierre méhaignerie
il laisse pantois sur le bord de la
route
le président des jeunes démocrates
sociaux et son trésorier
flashback avec françois léotard il
sellette avant-hier à nouveau contrat de
mariage
devant des militants et bailly pierre
magne rim est alors contraint et forcé
de dévoiler ses ambitions il faut un
chef au centre il sera celui-là lé
normal
que le président d'une formation
politique et c'est ce qu'attendent les
jeunes puissent être un jour premier
ministre alors dans quelles conditions
vous rêvez d'être premier ministre
nous sommes en 1989 l'alternance et 1,93
moi je suis confiant nous verrons si
nous sommes les meilleurs je pense que
nous avons la capacité d'être les
meilleurs et vous êtes candidat à un
poste de premier ministre mais on n'est
pas candidat au poste de premier
ministre et celle à base ce sont les
jeunes qui font cet appel et il est
normal qu'un dirigeant politique puisse
assumer cette fonction et je pense que
comme d'autres je peux l'assumer par
contenant les pierre méhaignerie n'est
pas seul sur la ligne de départ
valéry giscard d'estaing et françois
léotard revêtirait volontiers la
combinaison de plongée d'un nouveau
premier ministre de françois mitterrand
il faudrait alors être à la tête du
groupe parlementaire le plus fort mais
contrairement à la citadelle de saint
tropez qui sera bientôt vendue aux
enchères matignon n'est pas à vendre
voilà ne pas confondre avec le chapitre
précédent on passe maintenant vrai
cinéma avec l'ouverture du festival du
film américain à deauville l'amérique
qui nous envahit régulièrement de ses
productions mais qui vient au cul
également régulièrement chercher son
inspiration en europe et notamment en
france
les américains parce qu'il n'aime pas
les films doublés c'est du moins la
version officielle qui est fourni on
peut aussi parler de protectionnisme
eh bien ces américains préfèrent acheter
les droits du neuf et la retourner
ce fut le cas récemment pour trois
hommes et un couffin
c'est le cas en ce moment du célèbre
film de tacchella cousins cousines
reportage de claudine mulard à los
angels des fêtes de famille bien arrosée
deux couples mariés tish hélary tom et
maria un chassé croisé entre mary épouse
et pour finir maria interprété par
isabella rossellini qui choisira tome en
allant voir le film américain cousins
les spectateurs français vont sûrement
une impression de déjà vu
souvenez vous marie christine barrault
et victor lanoux
c'était en 76 cousins cousines un film
de jean charles tacchella adulé en
amérique est nommé trois fois aux oscars
le film euro traverse aujourd'hui
l'atlantique dans sa version
hollywoodienne et pour le réalisateur de
ce remake c'est un hommage de plus rendu
l
original si le film français n'avait pas
été un succès s'il n'avait pas déjà été
tournés je ne pense pas que jamais cette
histoire aurait pu être écrite par un
scénariste américain ce n'est pas le
genre de film et produisant
habituellement est donc livrée scénario
français et leur audace mais pour qu'un
film plaise au grand public américain il
faut adapter l'histoire et surtout la
rendront plus morale dans le film
original
l'adultère fait partie chaque jour la
vie de tout le monde à la fin des deux
amants vont au lit en présence et la
famille entière
le jour de noël ce n'est pas le genre de
choses que l'on peut faire aux états
unis
je veux dire mais ce serait quelque
chose enfin ce serait difficile à
montrer dans un film parce que le public
ne pouvait pas l'accepter
nous avons des principes très puritain
ici et puis vous savez écouter on a
peut-être plus d'adultère ici qu'en
france
simplement nous ne considérons pas que
ce soit une façon de vivre acceptable ce
qui fait que dans le film les gens sont
contre n y faire face comme un problème
réel
cette chasse
cointe
pour un rôle jugé périlleux en amérique
le réalisateur a choisi isabella
rossellini la seule actrice capable à
ses yeux de remplacer marie christine
barrault
après un rôle torturé dans blue velvet
il avait là s'aventure dans un
répertoire romantique plus proche de
celui de sa mère ingrid bergman
ce qui m'a fait d'abord c'était le
scénario je trouvais que l'histoire
était drôle chaleureux et puis j'ai
prouvé vraiment de la sympathie pour le
personnage que j'avais à jouer en fait
j'aimais déjà beaucoup la version
originale cousins cousines les trois
remakes de films français tourné
récemment hollywood ont très bien marché
au box office américain
mais en france c'est une autre affaire
trois hommes et un bébé adapté de trois
hommes et un couffin n'a pas tenu
longtemps salle le remake des fugitifs
de francis veber ne sortira même pas ici
alors au public français de décider
comment
treize ans après il va accueillir ses
cousins d'amérique
on sort pas vraiment du cinéma ou plus
exactement du vaudeville avec ce nouveau
faux départ pour le footballeur argentin
maradona ce matin à buenos aires il est
allé jusqu'au pied de l'avion cette fois
ci mais il n'y avait paraît-il plus de
place en 1ère difficile à croire cette
mascarade dans la mesure où même en
argentine je suppose
on ne prend pas son ticket d'avion au
dernier moment mais dans cette affaire
tout est possible même une erreur de
réservation
le vrai sport maintenant avec le départ
à southampton en angleterre ce matin du
tour du monde à la voile par équipe neuf
mois en mer francis mentaux
23 monocoque géant au départ de
southampton ce matin pour un tour du
monde à la voile avec 6 et à 61 mille
kilomètres 9 mois de navigation pour
revenir justement la case départ
southampton
mais au printemps seulement avant les
bourgeons les galères les mers du sud
bien sûr les quarantièmes rugissants des
50e hurlants tu laisses là ce sera
cependant les freins avant l'épreuve
déjà des problèmes pour l'équipage
féminin par exemple problèmes de
sponsors qui semble se défiler mais les
filles relève le défi au départ aussi le
maxi soviétique
aeroflot une première avec un barreur
originaire de kiev alex english and co
qui annonce la couleur
l'objectif prioritaire l'admiral ce qu
il vient donc pour apprendre il vient
pour gagner
alain gabet sur le maxi charles jourdan
pour gab est la vitesse moyenne demeure
l'un des secrets de la victoire autre
favori pierre fehlmann dernier vainqueur
en date
enfin côté français toujours un tabarly
peut en cacher un autre
patrick encouragé par eri prend
également le départ sur esprit de
liberté
conclusion est bien neuf mois de liberté
pour tous ces équipages qui entame cette
cinquième édition de la whitbread
voilà neuf mois donc sans jouer au
tiercé pour gagner cet après midi au
tiercé aux cartes et des il fallait
jouer le 13 le 5 et le 6 qui rapporte
4692 35 ans et pour ce qui concerne le
kart et vous allez voir les chiffres
s'inscrire sur votre écran vous rajoutez
le 16 et vous gagnez un peu moins de 30
mille francs
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après les prévisions météo joseph
dans la pierre le dernier journal aux
alentours de 23h30 vous sera présentée
par philippe gas vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur notre chaîne et je
vous dis à demain 13h soir